bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir un député philosophe bonsoir
François Xavier béami bonsoir et merci
d'être notre grand témoin vous publiez
espérer chez Grasset un mot qu'on a
tendance à s'interdire aujourd'hui face
au chaos du monde et pourtant et bien
c'est justement dans la crise pour vous
qu'il faut retrouver l'espérance dans sa
dimension politique philosophique et pas
forc ment religieuse on va en parler on
va aussi parler d'Europe parce que vous
êtes député européen et sans doute chef
de fil les républicains pour les
élections de juin prochain on en parlera
tout à l'heure notre grand débat ce soir
que faire face à la flambée antisémite
dans notre pays depuis le 7 octobre les
actes antisémites explosent avec des
slogans de haine des appels au meurtres
ou encore des insultes sur les réseaux
sociaux les Juifs de France ont peur
alors que fait-on pour les protéger on
parle dans un instant sur ce plateau
avec mes invités enfin nos affranchi ce
soir le billet d'actu de maître Bertrand
Perrier le mot de la semaine de Mariette
d'grand et puis action planè la
chronique écolo de Léa Falco voilà pour
le menu on y va François gavier bami ça
vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
maintenant certains parlent publiquement
d'un ortation du conflit
israélo-palestinien il s'agit bien d'une
flambée d'antisémitisme dans notre pays
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait concrètement
bonsoir Caroline yadan bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes député renaissance
de Paris bonsoir Anne Sophie sebanbecach
bonsoir bienvenue directrice de l'ajic à
Paris l'American Jewish commite bonsoir
Samuel le joyeux ravi de vous accueillir
vous êtes le président de l'ogf l'Union
des étudiants juifs de France enfin
bonsoir à Minel bi bonsoir ravi de vous
accueillir également juriste en droit
public à roubet inutile de dire François
g bami que vous pouvez intervenir quand
vous le souhaitez dans dans ce débat qui
nous concerne tous on va d'abord faire
le point sur ce qui se passe
concrètement dans le pays quelle est la
nature précise de ces actes antisémites
qui bondissent on voit cela avec
Stéphane blackakowski dans son chrono
tout de
suite et je me retourne pour vous
accueillir comme chaque soir mon cher
Stéphane je vous invite à faire la même
chose bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et tous
combi combien d'actes antisémit et bien
on a vu le chiffre s'afficher ce matin
dans la presse 719 incidents antisémites
c'est le terme officiel recensé depuis
l'attaque terroriste du Hamas contre
Israël ce qui signifie que en 20 jours
donc il y a eu plus d'actes antisémite
en France que pendant toute l'année
dernière en 2022 où on en a compté 436
donc une fois de plus on insiste à ce
que vous disiez l'importation du conflit
israélo-arabe en France c'est pas
nouveau regardez c'est la courbe des
actes antisémites depuis les années 2000
vous voyez que avant l'année 2000 très
très peu d'actes antisémites en France
ce qui semble tout déclencher c'est la
première antifada qui va de 2000 à 2005
vous voyez on a des pics jusqu'à près de
1000 actes antisémites puis après chaque
opération militaire contre Gaza depuis
Israël 2009 2014 à nouveau des pics qui
font remonter l'antisémitisme donc le
phénomène on ne le découvre pas je vous
propose d'écouter ce que disait
Christophe bourseillet le sociologue en
2004 sur ce sujet c'était donc il y a 20
ans il parlait d'un nouvel antisémitisme
en l'écoute il est important de faire
une distinction entre l'antisémitisme
traditionnelle qui émane de l'extrême
droite pour la plupart et qui
malheureusement constitue une vieille
tradition européenne et principalement
française et la judéophobie qui
constitue un phénomène relativement
nouveau dans la mesure où elle est liée
au conflit israelllo-arabe et à ses
dégâts collatéraux alors on rappelle que
la France est le pays d'Europe qui
compte à la fois la plus grande
communauté musulmane et la plus grande
communauté juive ce qui d'ailleurs nous
expose justement à l'importation du
conflit et aussi à des tensions
communautaires c'est déjà arrivé en 2018
une tribune avait été publié dans la
presse signé notamment par les
présidents Hollande et Sarkozi et euh
qui dénonçait le nouvel antisémitisme en
parlant même de d'un épurage ethnique à
bas bruit puisque certains juifs
quittaient des quartiers où il ne se
sentaient plus en sécurité euh les
musulmans étaient donc visé à travers
cette tribune et il s'était défendu en
disant que c'était injuste de les
accuser il en était indigné donc
logiquement évidemment avec le conflit
Hamas Israël
d'aujourd'hui il y a de nouveau ce
regain tension et c'est là que l'affaire
devient politique en effet on a beaucoup
reproché aux insoumis donc à jean-lur
milenchon de nier le caractère
terroriste de l'attaque contre Israël du
Hamas et sur le plan électoral c'est pas
forcément un bon calcul puisque plus de
80 % des Français désapprouve cette
position mais on peut imaginer que
Jean-Luc méenchon fait un autre calcul
ça ce sont les résultat de la
présidentielle et on a mis le vote
musulman en jaune donc vous voyez que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est le candidat qui
de très très loin attire le plus le vote
musulman et donc peut-être que il
imagine qu'en critiquant Israël il
pourrait renforcer son électorat de ce
point de vue reste bien sûr cette
éternelle question où est la limite
entre antisionisme et antisémitisme ben
voilà un cas concret pour de polémique
puisque Jean-Luc Mélenchon a fait ce
tweet en euh pardon de Br suivait donc
la présidente de l'Assemblée en lui
disant qu'elle campait à T vive pour
encourager le massacre donc en disant ça
il sait bien que y privé est juif d'une
part et surtout qu'elle reçoit
régulièrement des menaces de mort
antisémite qui oblige de renforcer la
sécurité dans son entourage donc on
écoute la réaction de la
présidente connaissant un peu Jean-Luc
Mélenchon je suis convaincu
qu'effectivement le mot camper n'a pas
été choisi par hasard et que le fait que
je favorise les massacres c'est à
nouveau une nouvelle cible qu'on me met
dans le dos me désigner comme étant
voilà
étant enfin je sais pas je je suis
désolée mais je
suis je suis très choquée en fait voilà
donc où nous en sommes 20 jours après le
début du conflit je vous laisse débattre
en rappelant que on s'attend à une
éventuelle opération terrestre en Israël
qui pourrait ajouter encore à
l'attention donc on a le droit de
s'inquiéter mais place au débat merci
merci beaucoup Stéphane Caroline yadan
on voit bien que les vannes de
l'antisémitisme sont grande ouvertes
depuis le 7 octobre évidemment on est
tous choqués quel que soit d'ailleurs no
nos origines est-ce que vous êtes
surprise je ne suis pas surprise euh je
suis en fait un peu
désespérée je ne suis pas surprise parce
que
l'antisémitisme en France au au 20e
siècle et au 21e siècle malheureusement
ne date pas d'hier je vous rappelle
qu'il analmie c'était il y a 17 ans il y
a 17 ans on a
guidnappé torturé à mort un jeune homme
parce qu'il était juif dans ce
pays et cette torture à mort s'est
accompagnée de tous les ponsif
antisémite qui passait par le
complottisme par Israël et cetera
c'était 17
ans il y a 17 ans très très peu de
personnes sont descendu dans la rue
pourquoi a pas je précise il y a pas
d'agression physique
majeur il faut d'ailleurs s féliciter
pour le moment depuis ilanalmie 13
personnes juives ont été assassiné en
France parce que Juive c'était un signal
d'alerte extrêmement important pour dire
quelque chose ne va pas du tout dans ce
pays et d'ailleurs manuel Vals avait
très bien dit qui s'attaque aux Juifs
s'attaque à la République mais tout à
l'heure on a parlé d'importation du
conflit en fait on n'est pas dans
l'importation d'un conflit on est dans
un
prétexte qui est pris par les
antisémites de ce pays c'est-à-dire la
haine obscessionnelle d'Israël pour s'en
prendre au juifs et reprendre la
rhétorique islamiste d'un mouvement
terroriste qui s'appelle le Hamas vous
n'aimez pas cette cette expression
d'importation en fait c'est pas que je
ne l'aime pas c'est qu'elle ne
correspond pas en réalité à la réalité
parce qu'elle donne une sorte de de
légitimation de on prendrait un conflit
extérieur et en définitive bon bah ceux
qui sont pour ceux qui sont contre et
cetera r on est dans un prétexte
antisémite en France euh de ce qui on
parlera des réponses tout à l'heure
parce qu'il y a des interpellations
évidemment il y a des plaintes et
parfois même on arrive à retrouver grâce
au signalement Faros les personnes euh
qui insultent qui menacent
qui font un peu déferler leur haine sur
les réseaux le problème c'est que ça
prend du temps et donc voilà il y a
encore beaucoup à faire très
concrètement Samuel le joyeux moi
j'aimerais comprendre ce qui se passe à
l'université quel déferlement pourquoi
l'université semble particulièrement
concerné par cette flambée
d'antisémitisme tout simplement parce
que à l'université euh c'est là que sont
implantter majoritairement euh les
réseaux de l'extrême gauche euh et
aujourd'hui par exemple les réseaux du
NPA euh le NPA c'est quand même un parti
niste absolument dès le 7 octobre dès le
7 octobre c'està-dire il y avait pas eu
une seule réponse quelle qu'elle soit
d'Israël dès le 7 octobre alors que des
terroristes était encore en train
d'égorger des enfants on a un communiqué
du NPA qui dit on soutient la lutte
bravo aux Palestiniens donc c'est c'est
un niveau de violence on est encore à un
autre niveau que Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
cetera on en parlera de ça donc ça dans
les les universités concrètement alors
dans les universités ce climat qu'est-ce
qui s'y dit qu'est-ce qu'on constate ce
qu'on constate est ce qui est
extrêmement violent c'est que déjà les
étudiants juifs bah ils voient comme
tout le monde les images terrifiantes du
7 octobre ils sont sans doute touché
plus particulièrement dans leur chair
parce qu'il s'agit de Juifs et du pire
massacre de juifs depuis la Seconde
Guerre mondiale ils ont envie d'en
parler ils ont envie de rendre des
hommages et ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
à l'université mais pas seulement à
l'université c'est que dès qu'il y a une
démarche entreprise pour rendre hommage
aux victimes israéliennes il y a tout de
suite une menace ou une intimidation
derrière exemple bah exemple c'est ce
qui m'est arrivé dans un VTC j'étais
dans un VTC je parlais à un journaliste
de la douleur des étudiants juifs et de
cette catastrophe en Israël le chauffeur
du VTC a annulé la course et m'a jeté
brutalement dehors véritablement j'ai
évidemment porté plainte mais ça montre
ça ça montre que pour certains
apparemment il est insupportable qu'on
puisse entendre une douleur commise
envers des Juifs parce que ça rentre pas
dans leur logiciel c'est qu'il y a un
logiciel de les Juifs c'est pas des
c'est pas ils sont pas dans le le
typique le type des des victimes j'ai vu
le long Fred un bon français cette série
de tweet qui a fait lu JF mort au Juifs
inscrit sur le mur des toilettes à
tolbiak à assa un prof le 9 octobre 2
jours après le massacre du ramas dit à
ses élèves de se calmer sinon il leur
fait comme à la rêve parti les grandes
écoles aussi à sciencep difficile de
rendre hommage à à un ancien étudiant
c'est ça assassiné par le Hamas
absolument c'est c'est c'est partout
hein c'est vraiment partout c'est dans
toutes les universités qui a cette
ambiance là on est vraiment dans un
antisémitisme alors d'acte vous l'avez
rappelé et c'est important de le
rappeler il n'y a pas eu pour le moment
d'agression j'ai envie de dire grave on
est sur un antisémitisme du quotidien un
antisémitisme d'atmosphère un
antisémitisme qui engendre une angoisse
c'est marrant j'ai dans le même champ de
vision le titre du livre de François
xavierani espérer qu'il se trouve
reprend alors c'est pas la référence en
l'occurrence mais mais ça me fait penser
évidemment à la tigva l'hymne national
d'Israël c'est c'est le mot c'est
l'espoir et aujourd'hui les juif de
France ils sont dans l'angoisse plutôt
que dans l'espoir moi par ailleurs je
crois qu'il y a un enjeu et ça il y a un
enjeu de tout le monde des associations
juifes donc évidemment mais aussi de la
parole politique et cetera alors de
dénoncer l'antisémitisme évidemment
évidemment mais aussi de dire que les
juifs ils sont pas seulement là
aujourd'hui en train finalement d'avoir
peur de l'antisémitisme ils sont aussi
en train de se battre ils sont aussi en
train voilà de faire des collages les
collages sur les otages mais il y a des
gens qui viennent mais qu'on pas qui
avait jamais fait un acte militant de
leur vie donc c'est important
effectivement cette atmosphère
d'angoisse pour les Juifs c'est vrai
elle est elle est réelle mais il y a
aussi de l'espoir et de la combativité
c'est bien de rester aussi optimiste on
va la regarder je vous je vous donne la
parole juste après ce reportage de
Stéphanie despier qui é tout simplement
promené ce matin dans le 19e
arrondissement de Paris elle a rencontré
des habitants il faut dire que une
communauté juive importante y habite
alors dans quel état d'esprit sont-ils
quel sentiment les traverses ont-ils
tout simplement peur reportage Stéphanie
Despierre
regardez
dans ce quartier juif orthodoxe de Paris
l'inquiétude est palpable c'est
vendredis les habitants font leurs
courses avant le traditionnel shabbat
Sipora est enseignante à l'école de
filles au bout de la rue bien sûr qu'on
se sent menacé en tant que juif et en
tant que Français aussi on fait
attention à ce qui se passe autour de
nous quand on fait nos courses quand
quand on amène les les enfants à l'école
il y a des gens qui se font livrer leurs
courses aussi au lieu d'aller
directement au magasin plusieurs
habitants racontent qu'en ce moment ils
font profil bas qu'ils sentent des
regards insistants voire pire
personnellement bah voilà je mets pas
laquipage je mets la casquette et on
sent
vraiment une hausse d'antisémitisme
samedi je suis parti à la
synagogue un petit un enfant de 10 ans
un musulman qui qui doit être très
gentil mais bon il je suis passé devant
lui et il a fait comme si qu' crachait
quoi un enfant de 10 ans donc je trouve
ça assez fou c'est la qui vient des
parents enfin peut pas expliquer ce
qu'on ressent quoi on se sent plus du
tout en sécurité un père de famille qui
veut rester anonyme nous raconte la
tentative d'agression que son fils a
subi j'ai mon fils qui s'est fait un peu
molester
mais on on a essayé de l'agresser mais
il a réussi à à se sauver il a eu
des des menaces s
juif s'occuper de vous j'ai l'impression
que il y avait une haine qui existait
j'ai l'impression que là elle ressort
c'est des prétextes pour ressortir cette
a vous avez l'impression que vous n'êtes
pas assez protégé par l'état non non on
sent que il y a y a une vraie protection
qui s'est mise en place dans les
synagogues dans les écoles on voit ça on
l'état s'occupe très sérieusement du
problème certains commerçants ont refusé
qu'on filme leur deventure par peur
d'être pris pour cible d'autres refusent
seulement de nous parler ils veulent
rester discrets pour ne pas entretenir
disIl la paranoïa on sent aussi de la
résignation face à cet antisémitisme
ambiant on va dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'il y a un conflit c'est un petit peu
ce qui se passe donc on a pris
l'habitude elle espère que le conflit
cette fois ne sera pas trop long voilà
on a pris l'habitude on a pris
l'habitude d'avoir peur Anne Sophie se
bécach on a l'impression quand même que
cette peur elle est plus importante que
après les les
différentes moments de de conflit entre
Israël et et le ramas ouais bien sûr
elle est plus importante c'est vrai
qu'elle était préexistante comme l'a dit
cette cette jeune fille nous on la on
l'a mesuré par exemple dans l'étude
qu'on publie radiographie
d'antisémitisme en France sur
l'expérience des Français juifs elle est
déjà majoritaire puisque plus de 74 %
des Juifs ont déjà vécu un acte
antisémite et ce sentiment de de
vulnérabilité euh il augmente à chaque
fois que il y a des tensions
effectivement entre Israéliens et
Palestiniens on sait qu'il y a déjà des
stratégie d'évitement que mettent en
place les Français juifs on évite la re
la porte du B porter des signes
distinctifs parce qu'on sait aussi que
les personnes juives portant des signes
distinctifs sont plus sujettes à des à
des agressions physiques et aujourd'hui
nous ce qu'on entend on va le mesurer on
va continuer de le mesurer mais ce qu'on
entend depuis le 7 octobre c'est plus
que de la stratégie d'évitement c'est
des techniques d'invisibilisation il
faut bien avoir ça en tête c'est que les
Juifs aujourd'hui en France font tout
pour ne plus qu'on les voit comme juifs
et Samuel a témoigné son expérience dans
un VTC j'en ai entendu depuis 10 jours
plusieurs notamment d'un change leur nom
c'est ça des personnes qui changent leur
nom déjà sur leur compte euh euh de VTC
sur leur compte de livraison à domicile
par peur d'être identifié comme juifs
des témoignage aussi d'agression un ami
d'amis qui d'ailleurs n'est pas juif
mais dont le chauffeur VTC lui a dit tu
as une tête de juif je vais le kidnapper
et il a dû sortir de son VTC en marche
c'est on on en est là on en est vraiment
plus à la stratégie d'évitement mais
effectivement à l'invisibilisation et à
ce sentiment de vulnérabilité absolue
qui je pense est est augmenté par le
traumatisme du 7 octobre il faut bien
aussi avoir ça en tête c'est que pour
beaucoup de Français juifs pour beaucoup
de Juifs dans le monde Israël était ce
sanctuaire ce lieu où on était en
sécurité cette notion là elle a été
ébranlé et donc à cette anxiété s'ajoute
cette cette extrême vulnérabilité qu'on
avait pas ressenti depuis la Choa faut
le dire Aminel B comment comment on
comprend ce qui se passe est-ce que
c'est à chaque fois la même chose il y a
plusieurs couches dans notre pays
d'antisémitisme vous le rappeliez madame
la député il y a un antisémitisme
classique d'extrême droite il y a
maintenant ce qu'on pourrait appelé des
des des élus qui soufflent un peu sur
les braises et puis il y a les
islamistes qui sont présents on le sait
les Frères musulmans dans dans notre
pays euh qui nourrit cet antisémitisme
de façon majoritaire aujourd'hui ce qui
nourrit l'antisémitisme de façon
majoritaire dans notre pays depuis
maintenant 30 ans ces 30 années de
politique de renoncement de relâchement
c'est une submersion migratoire c'est
l'acceptation d'un culte musulman
totalement D organisé je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous quand l'on place
uniquement le débat de l'antisémitisme
avec l'importation du conflit
israelllo-palestinien et la place du
Hamas je ne partage absolument pas cet
avis pour être tout à fait clair existe
c'est ça se réveille à ce momentl
maisàis le problème est institutionnel
que le problème s'est profondément créé
dans la société française parce que tous
nos responsables politiques et j'ai
envie de vous dire tous ceux qui se sont
succédés à la tête du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui ont présidé le bureau
des cultes qui se situe à l'intérieur
même de la place beauovau euh qui ont
accepté de s'asseoir à la table de
l'islam consulaire des pays du Maghreb
de la Turquie du Qatar et de toutes
celles et ceux qui aujourd'hui ont pris
en otage une religion l'Islam qui
concerne plus de 6 millions de
compatriotes musulmans qui ont décidé
d'agir et de parler au nom de nos
compatriotes musulmans qui aujourd'hui
euh on l'a m mis sur l'organisation du
culte ce sont eux qui désignent les
imams ce sont eux qui payent les
salaires des imams et ces imams sont à
la botte de pays étrangers c'est pas un
problème religieux c'est un problème de
souveraineté c'est un problème de
souveraineté politique c'est un problème
aussi de choix politique et de cohérence
politique alors il est lourd ce procès
que vous faites d'uneis désolé dire
depuisant 30 ans euh nous avons accepté
par le renoncement par la lâcheté
politique tout est son contraire
notamment parce que l'immigration est
contre contrôleré à sa responsabilité et
ce n'est pas seulement le problème de
l'immigration c'est même un problème
j'ai envie de vous dire qui est propre à
la communauté musulmane quand on accepte
d'isoler le mot allahakbar qui est quand
même entonné cinq fois par jour à
l'occasion de la prière par nos 6
millions de compatriotes musulmans sur
la place de la République euh proche du
Bataclan euh un jour de recueillement où
d'ailleurs on on avait enterré le matin
même le professeur Bernard décapité euh
euh tué égorgé plutôt sous le nom d'All
Akbar à haras ça a du sens c'est parce
que nous avons accepté que des
associations qui sous prétexte de cause
palestinienne madame ces mêmes
palestinienne emprunte le nom d'Allah
d'Allah Akbar vous savez Allah Akbar
c'est le nom qu'on anentonné mes
grands-parents qui pri Allah et qui ont
été tués avec l'amour que nous portons
tous pour le drapeau tricolore ils ont
instrumentalisé le nom d'une religion
ils ont souillé le nom d'une religion et
ils veulent aujourd'hui diviser notre
nation et je va je vais même vous dire
que ces personneslà ce sont les mêmes
qu'on entend pas lorsque les minorités
musulmanes sont persécutés comme jamais
en Birmanie ce sont les mêmes qui
s'indignent pas lorsque des compatriotes
musulmans sont réduits à l'état
d'esclavage c'est le cas des en Chine
les prières victimes de l'islamisme
l'inté la communauté il faut que vous
répondiez parce qu'il est très lourd le
procè que vous fait am Minel B aussi
bien à la députée Renaissance que vous
êtes pour républicain au fond 30 ans
d'échec d'aveuglement à combattre
clairement l'islamisme l'islam politique
même dans notre pays on pense à Nicolas
Sarkozi qui avait donné du pouvoir à
l'uif par exemple les Frères musulmans
on pourrait parler des tentatives
infructueuses aussi d'Emmanuel Macron à
organiser le culte qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ce
procès moi j'ai j'ai je n'ai pas été au
pouvoir je ne sais pas ce que c'est non
mais je veux pas dire ça c'est pas une
c'est votre famille politique qui est
mise en cause aussi bien que que celle
d'Emmanuel Macron d'une certaine façon
on on est c'est certain devant une
faillite je l'ai écrit moi-même je suis
pas le je suis pas surpris par ce que
dit Amin bi qui mène par ailleurs un
combat incroyablement courageux contre
l'intégrisme islamiste dans sa viille la
roubé et et et et et qui
a montré à quel point ce combat
impliquait parfois de payer le le prix
fort je je je je veux pas faire une
facilité de langage je me borne à
constater qu'en effet nous payons
aujourd'hui le résultat une faillite
collective qui date d'il y a bien avant
1 2 3 quinquena qui est faillite
collective c'est important parce que il
parle du Qatar il parle
descement il y a beaucoup de choses je
crois que c'est important de dire que
cette faillite collective elle est
collective c'est dire c'est la faillite
des élus mais c'est aussi la faillite
des citoyens un pays qui serait assez mû
pour regarder en face qu'il est en train
de traverser devrait dire nous avons
échoué et en tirer les conséquences non
pas pour passer notre temps à battre
notre coupe mais pour nous tourner vers
l'avenir pendant très longtemps tout le
monde a fermé les yeux ou beaucoup de
gens ont fermé les yeux et je mettrai
pas pour ma part tous les politiques sur
le même plan parce que on le voit aussi
aujourd'hui cet antisémitisme qui monte
il monte malheureusement dans le monde
musulman en France mais il monte
aussi dans des populations qui ne sont
pas du tout musulmanes dans des franges
de la société qui par pure idéologie
vous parliez de ce communiqué du NPA les
gens qui l'ont écrit je pense ne sont
pas musulmans vous parliez de ces
incroyables mots qui sont prononcés
aujourd'hui dans des universités
françaises mais c'est un problème qui
concerne le monde occidental en général
h interroger sur la question de savoir
si les souffrances des Palestiniens
justifient les attaques du Hamas 52 %
des étudiants américains répondent oui
ça c'est le signe de notre faillite
encore une et d'une faillite et d'une
faillite qui est aussi et je crois que
c'est un sujet majeur qui est aussi une
faillite éducative la crise que nous
vivons aujourd'hui elle est profondément
le résultat de la faillite migratoire de
l'incapacité de nos pays à à gérer leurs
frontières pour maintenir la possibilité
d'une unité nationale et défendre le
modèle que nous avons en commun mais
elle est aussi le résultat d'une
faillite éducative très profonde ça fait
très longtemps je le dis comme prof de
philo ça fait très longtemps qu'on sait
que les professeurs sont sous pression
en première ligne que l'enseignement de
la Choa est devenu difficile que parler
justement de la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme aujourd'hui est une
question qui et combien de professeurs
l'ont dit c'était il y a maintenant plus
de 10 ans les territoires perdus de la
République les auteurs de ce livre
lesurslec
avé en ce sens que je dis que tout le
monde estonsable lestiques mais aussi en
quelque sorte pardon je veux pas vous
renvoyer la
balle et notre vie civique collective
voilà le but c'est pas de chercher les
coupables le but maintenant c'est de
réagir et je dois dire une chose moi je
suis très marqué par ce que ce que vous
avez tous partagé je suis vraiment
équeuré et on le voit au Parlement
européen comme à l'Assemblée nationale
de voir
qu'aujourd'hui nous n'arrivons même pas
à avoir une l'animité de notre personnel
politique de notre monde politique de
nos élus pour dire que le terrorisme est
un scandale absolu au Parlement européen
ils sont pas là ils sont pas là pour se
défendre les insoumis sur ce plateau
donc vous les condamnez tous on avance
mais mais c'est pas c'est pas
négligeable vous parle j'ai reçu hier
les les familles des des des familles
d'otage retenu aujourd'hui en Israël des
familles de victimes tué lors du de
l'attentat du 7 octobre qu'est-ce qu'ils
peuvent penser quand il voi que dans nos
universités on arrache les photos
de leurs enfants retenus en otage ou
tués lors de cet attentat qu'est-ce
qu'ils peuvent penser quand nous en
arrivons à débattre de savoir si le
terrorisme est justifié ou
pas pr la mesure de la gravitéon je
voulais juste vous montrer une image et
vous allez me dire qu'est-ce qu'on fait
parce que quand vous dites que c'est un
combat de civilisation ou même un combat
qui dépasse largement notre pays il y a
quand même cette image qui est
absolument glaçante qu'on a vu en
Allemagne à Berlin des graffiti ont été
rensé le 15 octobre cette image elle a
fait un peu le tour du monde on a
vérifié ça n'est pas une fake news des
portes taguées à la peinture blanche
avec des étoiles de David pour marquer
les habitations juives ça nous fait
penser aux pires heures de l'histoire
donc c'est un phénomène qui existe
ailleurs hein que que dans notre pays
mais il est très puissant en France
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on peut pas que
protéger avec des militaires de
sentinelles devant les écoles et les
synagogues alors déjà on dit on dénonce
on condamne pardon mais si il y a une
franche politique je sais qu'ils ne sont
pas là mais il faut quand même le dire
qui porte une énorme
responsabilité dans le développement de
l'antisémitisme dans ce pays c'est LFI
quand on reçoit Jérémy Corbin quand on
reçoit Salah Amouri quand on est amis
avec belja qui dit Mohamed Mera c'est
moi et qui dit Mélenchon c'est mon
bulletin guerre lorsque
lorsque lorsque on tout à fait pardon
lorsqu'on traite le CRIF d'extrême
droite lorsqu'on dit Mohamed Berat en
définitive ses bateaux t ça la
déclaration de Mélenchon lorsqu'on dit
tous les Juifs sont prétendument à
priori tous zmouriens et donc on les
essentialise par rapport à non mais je
veux dire il il y a quand même des
déclarations et aujourd'hui l fi
franchit un cap franchit une ligne rouge
mais on on ne devrait même plus leur
adresser la parole de la même manière
qu'à un moment donné on a dit le RN est
plus fréquentable mais c'est terminé on
ne peut pas comme le fait mél
peut-être pour les raisons
électoralistes dont qu'on a développé
tout à l'heure on ne peut plus laisser
faire ce discours de haine envers les
Juifs qui son les propos les
l'entourage les prises de position qui
ATIS les brises de l'antisémitisme dans
ce pays et qui émane d' la fi et puis je
voulais juste dire un mot sur les médias
pardon mais moi lorsque je vois
l'humanité qui a fait la couverture
qu'il a fait mais je dis alors on peut
pas vous la montrer là on l' pas sous la
main mais je la résume je dis il Bron
Pivet Jordan Bardella alors image de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale nazi avec
les donc on a vraiment l'impression
c'est c'est une infamie en fait
c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qu'on dit
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui est dit dans
cette dans cette image avec marqué le
mot humanité parce que tout est fait au
nom de la morale au nom de l'humain au
nom du bien et cetera qu'est-ce qu'on
dit avec cette image on dit voilà nous
ciblons ces personnes h HM une est juive
qui sont rend en Israël et on les cible
par person ce sont des assassins qui
assassinent impunément les enfants à
Gaza c'est-à-dire qu'on est sur un
renvement total des valeurs où on fait
passer le bourreau pour les victimes où
on fait passer les terroristes pour des
résistants donc on est on est vraiment
sur
responsme et par
qui fait un parallèle entre le mouvement
terroriste du ramas et et et et et le le
gouvernement ou l'armée israélienne qui
est là pour protéger ces civils qui ont
été décimés 1400 civiles décimés
torturés brûlés vif voilà avec les
images les
images au médias mais à ces deux médias
que vous avez cité alors vous
représentez des associations Samuel le
joyeux et fils ce bécche qu'est-ce que
vous attendez concrètement qu'est-ce que
vous demandez au pouvoir public
évidemment la condamnation j'y reviens
pas je partage absolument on reviens pas
ce que ce que je constate quand même
c'est que on a on est quand même en
France il y a eu de la part de
l'ensemble des partis à l'exception de
la France insoumise des réactions
claires et on a une réponse sur le plan
sécuritaire qui à mon avis est à la
hauteur c'est le cas voilà du du du
ministère de l'intérieur comme du
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
non justement c'est là où c'est là où où
je dis donc on a une une réponse
sécuritaire de l'instant qui à mon avis
à la hauteur la question et là où je
suis assez quand même étonné c'est de
voir qu'il y a si peu de réflexion sur
le fond sur comment on en arrive là à
mon avis on dépasse le problème de la
place de l'islam et de l'islamisme ça va
plus loin il y a finalement une question
qui est pourquoi systématiquement quand
des Juifs sont tués il n'y a pas une
unanimité dans le pays pourquoi par
exemple je vois et et et on a évidemment
condamné on était là pour rendre hommage
à Dominique Bernard mais encore une fois
sur l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard on
a dit c'est la deuxième fois que le
terrorisme touche l'école comme on avait
dit pour Samuel paatti c'était la
première fois pourquoi encore une fois
les enfants d'utzaratora sont oubliés ne
sont pas pas considéré comme des morts
du terrorisme à l'école donc c'est un
moment ça c'est un moment la question
c'est sur l'unité de la nation autour de
valeurs de fraternité autour de valeurs
républicaines et cette idée que les
Juifs font partie de la République qui
estime qu'aujourd'hui les otages
français qui sont retenus par le ramas à
Gaza quel citoyens nonjuif considère que
c'est vraiment des Français il y a un
sentiment que ce sont des étrangers donc
à un moment pour moi la question c'est
ça le défi des politiques qui n'est pas
relevé c'est celui-là c'est de se dire
comment on fait pour que les Juifs c'est
ça l'angoisse quand même l'angoisse des
Juifs c'est aussi l'angoisse d'un
sentiment de solitude d'un sentiment
d'être lâché par la nation d'un
sentiment de ne plus faire partie
véritablement de la nation Anne Sophie B
cche oui alors évidemment je souscris à
tout ce qui a été dit par Madame yadan
par Samuel pour rajouter dans les
solutions dans ce qu'on pourrait faire
de plus je souscrit aussi à ce qu'a dit
Monsieur bamis sur l'éducation et je
crois que par rapport à ce qui a été dit
ce qu'on pourrait faire de plus c'est
mettre les moyens pour ce qui est de
l'éducation pour ce qui est de
l'enseignement de l'histoire des moyens
qui soient à la hauteur du phénomène
auquel on fait face qui effectivement ne
concerne pas les Juifs mais on sait très
bien que ce qui se trame c'est vraiment
l'avenir de notre pays ces
fractures ce
retournement de de l'information c'est
fake news et cetera c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment notre démocratie qui est en jeu
et on sait que le gouvernement est très
engagé sur le plan sécuritaire et cetera
mais sur le plan de de des moyens qui
sont mis je pense qu'on est pas encore à
la hauteur du phénomène l'éducation et
l'éducation à l'information si on
revient à ce qui nous ce qui nous
préoccupe depuis depuis 15 jours depuis
3 semaines maintenant c'est le conflit
israëpalestinien comment est enseigné
aujourd'hui en France le conflit
israëpalestinen si on a si on en
arriveutant on arrive à autant d'érance
si on en arrive à avoir des gens qui
disent des choses mais de l'ORD de
l'inacceptable on a parfois l'impression
de de parler avec avec l'absurde la
vérité devient le mensonge le mensonge
devient la vérité c'est qu'on a laissé
passer des choses et effectivement c'est
une faillite collective allez
l'appartenance à un nous républicain
l'éducation am Minel Bahi vous nous avez
dressé un un tableau des causes
profondes et et les racines du mal
anciennes qu'est-ce que vous vous
proposez qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire
oui nous avons un devoir d'action sortir
au-delà évidemment du cadre islamisme
antisémitisme cette idée de
responsabilisation évidemment de la
communauté musulmane cette idée aussi de
responsabiliser les acteurs
institutionnels et de choisir
évidemment un islam de France composé de
compatriotes français qui évidemment
pourrait nouer des liens et avoir aussi
ce discours je dirais même ce débat
intareligieux au-delà de de de cette
simple question religieuse
l'antisémitisme ne s'arrête pas
uniquement aux portes de l'islamisme
l'histoire de France l'a démontré une
fois de plus sû en 2014 par exemple on a
vu un un vieil antisémitisme d'extrême
droite Alain Soral qui faisait cette
idée de la réconciliation
entre les chrétiens extrémistes
d'extrême droite et et les musulmans sur
le dos des Juifs c'était les images de
2014 elles ont été extrêmement
extrêmement violent a pris la défense
dans le Jean-Luc Mélenchon là très
récemment hier ou avant donc il est
toujours là cet antisémitisme vous savez
je vais y arriver il y a un cyber
militant néonazi monsieur Boris leelit
qui se cache actuellement au Japon avec
plus de 22 condamnations pour des propos
antisémites des propos à caractère
raciste nous sommes lié la France et le
Japon par une convention judiciaire
d'extradition dont il appartient au seul
président de la République de demander
l'extradition d'un militant néonazi qui
se cache au Japon pour non seulement le
faire juger mais aussi l'incarcérer en
France nous attendons des réponses sur
cette question et peut-être un deuxième
point les députés de la République en
marche ont produit un rapport le rapport
Abadi une abadier il me semble madame
abadier qui a effectivement proposé à
travers un rapport parlementaire 5 qu1
propositions extrêmement intéressante
renforcer le devoir de mémoire
transmettre en matière d'éducation mais
aussi responsabiliser et surveiller les
réseaux sociaux et sur ce sujet précis
il y a eu 50 propositions 50
propositions qui une fois de plus sont
passé à la trappe aujourd'hui on a
besoin de simplifier le régime du droit
de la presse parce que vous avez des
personnes qui tiennent des propos à
caractère antisémite qui profite profite
de la comp la complexité du système
juridique français du régime de la
prescription du régime de la nulité et
qui à la
S r vous avez un devoir d'action et un
devoir de lucidité on a déposé justement
une une proposition de loi avec mon
collègue Mathieu Lefèvre exactement sur
le point que vous soulevez c'est-à-dire
Boris Lelay au Japon puisque jusqu'à
présent il n a il y avait une
impossibilité à délivrer un mandat
d'arrêt et notre proposition de loi sur
ce type de d'apologie notamment de
crimes contre l'humanité ou de CRIM de
guerre va faire l'objet si la
proposition de loi est votée d'une donc
d'un d'un d'un mandat d'arrêt et je
rappelle aussi que le le le texte qu'on
vient de voter à l'Assemblée nationale
le texte qu'on vient de voter à
l'Assemblée nationale sur les réseaux
sociaux va permettre d'ajouter une peine
de banissement des réseaux sociaux voilà
tout ça s'ajoute évidemment à la loi de
2021 confortant le respect des princip
de la r viur elle VI d'être voté à
l'assemblée cette fois on s'arrête là
merci merci pour vos témoignages et
merci pour pour vos analyses euh vous
restez avec moi François Xavi bamis dans
une dizaine de minutes les parties prix
de nos affranchis alors ce soir maître
Bertrand Perrier va revenir sur la
plainte américaine contre ma accusé
d'avoir porté atteinte à la santé
mentale des enfants le mot de la semaine
de Mariette d'égrand c'est le mot état
deux peuples deux états euh comme de
nombreux dirigeants euh le demandent et
puis dans Action planète de quoi nous
parlez-vous ce soir Léa Léa Falco on
parle d'un arrêté du Conseil d'État sur
les éoliennes à tout à l'heure les les
amis mais d'abord peut-on rêver d'un
monde sans violence c'est l'une des
questions que vous posez François Xavier
bami vous nous invitez à une réflexion
philosophique dans votre dernier dernier
livre espérer chez grassa alors où
personne ne s'autorise une véritable
espérance espoir vous nous dites
attention ça n'est pas de l'optimisme
mais c'est un mot qu'il faut retrouver
loin de la religion on a besoin d'une
explication c'est dans l'invitation de
Marco Pomier et on en parle tous les
deux juste
après si on vous invite François Xavier
bami c'est parce que vous avez troqué
vos habits de politique pour ceux de
philosophes avec une perspective renoué
avec l'espoir proposition étonnante
incongru loin d'être évidente face à un
monde bien sombre j'ai voulu parler
d'espoir parce que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce dont nous avons
le plus besoin se questionner sur
l'espérance pas étonnant finalement pour
un professeur agrégé de philosophie vous
êtes une tête bien faite François Xavier
bami normalien essayiste et députés
européens propulsé sur le devant de la
scène politique en 2019 tête de liste
des républicains aux européennes mais
c'est la D route 8 % des suffrages
seulement le pire score de la droite à
ces élections va bien tout va bien 8 %
tout va bien votre dernier ouvrage
s'inspire de vos soirées de la philo
depuis 10 ans d'un théâtre à l'autre
seul en scène vous philosopher sur des
séries de questions à travers les écrits
des maîtres à penser pourquoi nous
perpétuellement comme divisé comme
séparé de nous-mêmes pourquoi est-il si
compliqué d'être simple c'est la
question de cette nouvelle soirée de la
philo aujourd'hui le temps est à la
grande inquiétude dites-vous alors vous
invoquez les grands auteurs et leurs
réflexions Marx Hegel hobs mackiavel
avec trois grandes méditations sur la
violence le progrès et la quête du
bonheur mais il ne faut pas s'y tromper
ce n'est pas un livre seulement
philosophique il est aussi politique
on sait d'ailleurs votre envie de
conduire à nouveau la liste de la droite
aux européennes de 2024 et c'est plutôt
bien parti franis Xavier bam serait un
bon candidat pour conduire la liste
serait un bon bon candidat il a beaucoup
de qualités il les a démontré alors
puisque vous parlez d'espoir François
Xavier bami on a une question pour vous
ce soir espérez vous faire des
européennes un trempelin pour d'autres
ambitions
politique réponse un trempelin pour une
action utile c'est la seule chose qui
compte l'ambition personnelle surtout
dans un moment aussi grave on vient d'en
parler l'ambition personnelle elle a sa
légitimité seulement et seulement si
elle est mise au service de quelque
chose de bien plus grand vous avez envie
de la mener cette liste non oui j'ai
envie de la mener pour être utile et
donc vous êt candidat ça clairement je
je serai candidat si le parti auquel
j'appartiens me fait confiance pour ça
j'ai travaillé pendant 5 ans avec pour
mandat d'être utile et c'est normal que
je remette maintenant ce mandat entre
les mains de ceux qui m'ont fait
confiance beaucoup 8 % mais c'est quand
même 2 millions d'électeurs qui nous ont
demandé de les représenter au Parlement
européen j'espère avoir été à la hauteur
de la mission il y a d'autres
prétendants sur le coup si je puis dire
on verra ça en temps vu il y a beaucoup
de de de politiques qui redoutent ces
élections européennes et qui voi que le
Parlement pourrait alors c'est du
conditionnel he basculer dans le le camp
des eurosceptiques avec les populistes
en faveur d'une alliance entre le Parti
populaire européen auquel vous
appartenez la droite en Europe et et des
partis populistes à sa droite est ce que
vous y croyez est-ce que vous le
souhaitez moi je crois que ce qui compte
vous savez le Parlement européen il y a
pas de coalition les majorités se
construisent texte par texte article par
article et on nous a fait des
recompositions à la faveur des élections
aussi et des majorités ce qui est sûr
c'est que aujourd'hui sur des sujets
majeurs il faut être au rendez-vous de
la clarté je je on vient de parler de la
menace terroriste qui touche le monde
mais notre pays aussi en particulier et
cette menace terroriste elle est
directement liée par exemple à la
fragilité de nos états en matière de
politique que migratoire et aujourd'hui
ce qui me frappe c'est que quand on
essaie de mettre ce sujet sur la table
pour avancer concrètement on nous fait
systématiquement toujours encore
aujourd'hui un procès en radicalisation
en extrémisme on a déposé un amendement
par exemple il quelqu Mo à Bruxelles y
compris à Bruxelles parce que ce sont
les mêmes élus et notamment nos nos
collègues macronistes qui nous
expliquent que ouvrir les yeux sur cette
question c'est déjà d'une certaine façon
transgresser des interdits moraux on a
déposé un amendement très simple pour
que le budget européen puisse servir à
financer des infrastructures physiques
aux frontières extérieures de l'Union
européenne c'est-à-dire des murs dans
certains endroits où c'est pertinent
c'est pas nous qui le demandons c'est
aussi des états des gouvernements de
plusieurs tendances politiques la Grèce
la Bulgarie qui ont une frontière avec
la Turquie la Pologne la Lituanie avec
la Russie ou la Biélorussie et qui voit
à quel point H a déjà fait hein de son
côté sans demander l'accord des 27 mais
beaucoup de pays l'ont déjà fait la
Finlande l'a déjà fait c'est un ministre
écologiste qui a fait construire une une
frontière un mur de plusieurs centaines
de kilomètres de long avec la Russie pas
pour arrêter des chars parce que les
chars seraient pas arrêtés par des fils
de faire barbeler mais pour arrêter des
migrants on voit bien à quel point
l'immigration aussi est utilisée comme
une arme hybride pour déstabiliser nos
états c'est ce qu'a fait Erdogan c'est
ce qu'a fait Lukashenko donc aujourd'hui
on a cette nécessité devant nous et bien
quand nous disons ça que répondent nos
collègues macronistes que répond la
gauche d'une seule voix ils disent tous
oh là là mais vous faites une alliance
avec l'extrême droite non nous nous
défendons notre ligne et cette ligne
elle est claire parce que dans un moment
comme celui qu'on vit on n'a pas le
droit à l'ambiguitïé on a plus le droit
en même temps on doit assumer la clarté
de nos convictions alors je on ver don
que des élus qui viennent de partout qui
viennent de la gauche si ils deviennent
lucides et sils veulent rejoindre no
conviction et bien que que que des élus
puissent se saisir de ces enjeux
fondamentaux j'espère que le Parlement
européen dégagera une majorité claire
pour agir sur ces sujets comme sur bien
d'autres alors de quoi parlez-vous
précisément quand vous parlez
d'espérance espérance on on pense tous
au christianisme c'est une des valeurs
cardinales l'espérance et vous nous
dites c'est pas forcément ça espérer ça
peut être philosophique ça peut être
politique en tout cas ça n'est pas
l'optimisme explication
oui c'est difficile de parler
d'espérance aujourd'hui parce qu'on vit
évidemment dans un moment tellement
sombre que que espérer ressemble à une
provocation mais ce que j'ai voulu
montrer justement c'est d'une certaine
manière on en a aussi besoin c'est que
espérer justement c'est le contraire
d'être optimiste vous savez quand on a
des conversations ou bien qu'on qu'on
intervient en public il y a une sorte de
convention sociale qui fait que quand on
a fait la liste de tout ce qui va pas on
termine en disant mais quand même il
faut être optimiste pas forcément il y a
des moments où l'optimisme évidemment
est un mauvais guide et n'est pas fondé
des moments où on n' pas de raison
d'être optimiste et dans ces moments-là
il faut regarder la réalité en face
alors c'est quoi pasopisme et bien ça
veut dire just le courage l'engagement
ça veut dire choisir d'agir comme si une
victoire était possible même quand dans
l'immédiat elle paraît bien éloignée
choisir de vivre pour un bien qui semble
presque improbable même quand encore une
fois on mesure les difficultés c'est la
non la France d'ailleurs a été sauvée
plusieurs fois dans son histoire par des
actes d'espérance prenez le 18 juin 40
j'imagine que de Gaul quand il est à
Londres n'est pas précisément optimiste
et que ceux qui le rejoignent au tout
début de cette guerre terrible n'ont pas
le sentiment que ils peuvent parier sur
l'optimisme rayonnant sur l'avenir de de
notre pays mais ils font un acte
d'espérance c'est-à-dire ils engagent
leur vie entière pour une victoire qui
semble très éloignée et très incertaine
parce qu'elle vaut la peine qu'on donne
tout si il y a une chance qu'elle puisse
se réaliser et voyez une chose
intéressante c'est que l'optimisme comme
le pessimisme d'ailleurs sont une
manière de se désengager si vous pouvez
dire par principe que tout va bien se
terminer et bien il y a pas de raison
d'agir si vous pouvez dire par principe
que tout va s'effondrer il y a pas de
raison d'agir non plus l'espérance au
contraire c'est une disposition à agir
pour ça d'ailleurs que c'est une forme
de vertu pour parler un langage
désormais un peu obsolète ouais mais
cette vertu comment on la transmet dans
un monde effectivement à l'agonie où les
jeunes franchement euh n'ont pas
beaucoup de perspectives entre les
guerres et le réchauffement climatique
est-ce qu'on n'est pas un peu naïf quand
on on met en avant cette vertu non au
contraire parce que l'espérance il y a
un très beau texte de Bernanos en 1942
là encore dans dans cette période très
sombre pour l'histoire du monde Bernanos
en 42 écrit euh la plus haute forme de
l'espérance c'est le désespoir surmonté
l'espérance n'est pas le dénis de
réalité qui nous a conduit à l'impasse
dans laquelle on se trouve aujourd'hui
l'espérance consiste à dire nous voyons
et nous voulons voir et nous voulons
regarder avec courage toutes les
difficultés du moment que nous
traversons mais nous choisissons d'agir
malgré tout envers et contre tout ce qui
pourrait nous décourager il faut avoir
été au bout du découragement pour
pouvoir espérer à nouveau pour pouvoir
espérer vraiment espérer sérieusement
alors on a pris quelques philosophes
pour essayer de mieux comprendre parce
que vous voilà multiplier les références
autour de trois grandes questions la
première c'est peut-on espérer un monde
sans violence et vous convoquZ egle
alors lui c'est plutôt la fin de
l'histoire c'est la dialectique du
maître et de l'esclave bon je suis
niveau terminale hein pas pas plus que
ça mais pour sortir de la violence pour
lui il faudrait sortir de l'histoire
sans ça le monde serait condamné à la
violence donc le monde est par essence
violent
Gul a été l'un des philosophes qui a
malheureusement servi de préparation au
20e siècle terrible que nous avons connu
parce que Hegel était convaincu que pour
arriver à la fin de l'histoire qui
serait une sorte de paix perpétuel ce
qu'on pourrait appeler ce qu'il appelait
le le dimanche de la vie voilà une sorte
d'utopie pour arriver à la fin de
l'histoire il fallait utiliser d'une
certaine manière où il fallait accepter
admettre que la violence était un moyen
et et c'est notamment chez egle la
figure du grand homme Napoléon qui
l'admirait tant le grand homme qui
écrase main de fleurs innocentes sur son
chemin il faut bien aller au bout de son
destin et pour aller au bout de son
destin et bien tant pis d'une certaine
façon pour les victimes innocentes qu'on
peut créer autour de soi dans ce livre
j'ai cité des auteurs qui ne
correspondent pas à nécessairement
seulement à ma position personnelle mon
but
c'est de conduire le le le le le lecteur
comme en fait en réalité ce sont au
départ des des cours de philo des
conférences de philosophie de conduire
ceux qui suivent ces ces ces cours ces
enseignements jusqu'à une réflexion
personnelle en passant par le fait de se
confronter à des auteurs qui ne pensent
pas la même chose que nous et bien ce
que egle nous montre au fond ce qu'on
peut retenir de lui c'est cette cette
cette nécessité de trancher quant au
rapport à la violence et je crois que
c'est fondamental dans un un moment
comme celui qu'on est en train de
traverser aujourd'hui où on entend on le
disait tout à l'heure des responsables
politiques qui d'une certaine manière
viennent aussi de la tradition marxiste
qui est une tradition égélienne et qui
nous explique que finalement le
terrorisme B ça peut se justifier que
quand il faut se libérer d'une
oppression on peut en venir à commettre
des crimes y compris contre des victimes
innocentes je crois que lire hgle c'est
aussi nous rappeler de la nécessité de
trancher ce débat d'une façon qui soit
très claire jamais la violence ne peut
devenir en tant que telle un moyen
légitime d'action si ce n'est pour se
défendre contre une agression mais
jamais la violence comme une moyen de
faire avancer une cause c'est très
intéressant d'ailleurs cette question
entre entre violence et politique pour
Anna arent je passe sur Emmanuel Kant on
a plus le temps mais pour Anna arent
c'est antinomique exp expliquez-nous ça
la politique ne peut pas être par
essence violente ce qui est contraire
des gueul et de beaucoup d'autres
exactement et moi je suis vraiment
profondément convaincu que ce que arent
a à nous dire estun grande actualité la
politique nous dit Aren c'est une
manière de parler du monde c'est une
conversation c'est une victoire contre
la violence c'est-à-dire une manière
d'installer l'espace d'une discussion
nous rencontrons des désaccords nous
vivons des problèmes et bien bien sûr
ils font naître entre nous des
divergences majeures mais ces
divergences et ça aussi c'est un choix à
faire pour notre démocratie aujourd'hui
est-ce que de nos désaccord nous faisons
l'occasion d'une conversation ou d'une
confrontation on est ici à l'Assemblée
nationale et on voit que cette question
elle se pose y compris dans le travail
parlementaire pour n aussi au Parlement
européen est-ce qu'on assume que au-delà
de nos divergences il peut y avoir une
forme d'unité civique d'amitié civique
c'est ce dont Aren parle ça peut
paraître idéaliste mais en réalité c'est
ce que nous vivons V tous les jours dans
le travail démocratique de dans le plus
petit conseil municipal de France comme
à l'Assemblée nationale nos divergences
nos désaccords sont des occasions de
conversation et je crois que c'est cette
intuition profonde que les démocraties
ont la charge de retrouver on vit aussi
une fragilisation du modèle démocratique
dans le monde qui est concurrencé par la
montée des totalitarisme de de des
dictatures des États autoritaires qui
veulent faire la preuve qu'ils sont plus
efficace qu'ils arrivent eux à leur fin
ce que nous avons à démontrer c'est que
la démocratie cette conversation civique
elle doit pouvoir faire la preuve de sa
robustesse et son efficacité merci
beaucoup François Xavier Mélanie espérer
pour peut-être se réconcilier sans
forcément tomber d'accord dans dans une
démocratie qui a besoin d'être défendu
merci infiniment c'estàdire chez Grasset
vous restez avec moi c'est l'UR des
parti pris de nos affranchis ils vont
vous faire réagir j'en suis sûr on les
accueille tout de
suite Bertrand Perrier maître Bertrand
Perrier son AR oratoire installez-vous
Mariette d'igrand et son mot de la
semaine on commence comme chaque soir
par pas comme chaque soir comme chaque
vendredi soir parler à Falco et et sa
rubrique et cololo action planè bonsoir
Léa vous nous parlez ce soir des
éoliennes c'est ça c'est ça et plus
précisément d'un arrêt récent du Conseil
d'État sur un parc d'éolienne en neur
etloire et plus précisément à ilier
Combray alors le nom a son importance
parce que ilier Combray c'est évidemment
prou Marcel prou à la recherche du temps
perdu l'oncle de prou qui dessinait
lui-même les pay visage et donc c'est un
lieu relativement symbolique c'est
d'ailleurs l'explication qu'a donné le
Conseil d'État pour justifier le refus
d'installation de ce parc d'éolienne
avec je cite la prise en considération
des éléments ayant très aux dimensions
historiques mémoriell culturell et
notamment littéraire du paysage alors si
prou a obtenu gain de cause c'est pas
forcément très bon pour les éoliennes
bah disons que d'une part quand même ça
implique que la le secteur des éoliennes
pourrait prendre un petit coup d'arrêt
ce qui est d'autant plus dommageable
qu'on a un besoin fort de création
d'électricité bas carbone et que pour ça
les énergies renouvelables sont un
levier de déploiement rapide mais en
plus ça pose une autre question qui est
le rapport que nous avons au territoire
et surtout au paysage ce qui est
intéressant d'ailleurs historiquement il
y a un vrai lien entre les sujets
énergétiques et les sujets de territoire
de paysage puisque la première loi de
protection des sites en 1906 elle a été
votée après le projet de création d'une
centrale hydroélectrique cette fois dans
le Jura B alors le paysage qu'est-ce que
c'est aujourd'hui on a vraiment
l'impression que c'est un acquis quelque
chose qui ne bouge pas quelque chose qui
a toujours été comme ça sauf que c'est
le produit résultant d'une suite de
politique publique pas toujours très
cohérente qui impose de plus en plus
d'injonction parfois contradictoire aux
collectivités locales avec à côté des
opérateurs industriels pour qui la
concertation des populations qui
habitent là c'est pas toujours la
priorité et donc dans cette espèce de
globibibouga on se retrouve forcément
avec des réactions de rejet quand on a
une intrusion de nouveaux objets dans ce
territoire qui nous tient à cœur
justement parce qu'on en est le seul
observateur passif donc il y a une vraie
réflexion à avoir au-delà de juste cet
avis du du Conseil d'État sur la manière
dont on crée dont on implante ces
projets sur la manière dont il faut en
discuter démocratiquement avec les
habitants locaux au-delà de la simple
concertation qu'on organise une fois et
qu'ensuite on enterre et la manière dont
le paysage est vraiment perçu comme
quelque chose dans lequel on s'intègre
et pas seulement comme une carte postale
évidemment c'est plus facile à dire qu'à
faire mais de fait la transition
écologique ne se fera pas sans les gens
et si les territoires et les paysages
changent il faut que ce soit avec eux
une petite réaction moi je le processus
démocratique et les éoliennes le paysage
qui est pas forcément la nature qui est
amené à à bouger aussi le fait est
qu'aujourd'hui les éoliennes se sont
beaucoup implanté à terre comme en mer
contre la démocratie et notamment la
démocratie locale ou bien en essayant de
la subvertir par des moyens un peu
contournés c'est-à-dire en faisant en
sorte qu'on finance les communes dans
beaucoup d'endroits on va voir les
maires ou bien les agriculteurs en leur
proposant des subventions qui sont en
fait une manière finalement de de
d'acquérir leur bienveillance voilà en
réalité le vrai problème de fond pour
notre pays c'est quel est notre choix
industriel pour la production d'énergie
et aujourd'hui ce qui a été très
durement attaqué au plan européen mais
aussi d'ailleurs au plan national
puisque le gouvernement français dans le
premier qu' Canad Emmanuel Macron était
très hostile au nucléaire ce qui a été
attaqué c'est le plus grand atout de
notre pays pour produire une
égboné bac carbone une énergie pilotable
et une énergie accessible on REP le
débat c'est une petite réaction
seulement c'est un débat majeur pourquoi
implter des éoliennes partout si on a
décidé de miser sur cet atout moi je
crois qu'on est devant un contresens
historique et pour revenir à ce point
précis je suis très heureux que la
juridiction administrative française
reconnaisse que les paysages que les
paysages sont littéraires ça c'est quand
même très beau parce que ça permet aussi
de dire que les paysages sont rappel
néanmoins sur le fait que l'électricité
aujourd'hui c'est seulement 20 % de not
mix énergétiques donc non seulement il
faut faudra proba V du nucléaire mais
que pendant les 15 ans de construction
de ces centrales il faut bien qu'on ait
un levier sur lequel activver la
création d'un bien compris on va partir
aux États-Unis à présent avec vous
Bertrand cette semaine 42 États
américains ont déposé plainte contre MTA
la maisonberre de Facebook et et
Instagram accusé d'avoir délibérément
porté atteinte à la santé mentale et
physique des enfants et des ados oui 42
états démocrates comme républicain
d'ailleurs c'est pas une question
politique qui ont déposé plainte contre
la maison mer de Facebook et Instagram
l'entreprise de Mark Zuckerberg qui est
accusé d'avoir manipulé ses algorithmes
pour délibérément susciter une addiction
une dépendance des plus jeunes aux
écrans et notamment au aux réseaux
sociaux alors on connaît bien les les
technique mise en œuvre les les fameuses
bulles cognitives où on ne vous propose
sur les écrans que des choses que vous
avez déjà aimé la technique du scrolling
sans fin où on se dit que la vidéo
suivante sera peut-être encore plus
intéressante justement l'omniprésence
des vidéos qui sont beaucoup plus
attractifes que du texte et tout cela
crée chez les plus jeunes comme
d'ailleurs chez les adultes également
cette fameuse faux mot cette peur de
manquer quelque chose sur ces réseaux où
il se passe toujours quelque chose h et
avec on l'imagine aussi une
arrière-pensée commerciale mercantile
oui évidemment on est un peu comme le
débat qui avait eu lieu il y a quelques
années sur le tabac c'est-à-dire que une
entreprise fait des profits sur le dos
de la santé de ses clients et évidemment
ça avait déjà été dénoncé par une
lanceuse d'alerte francces Hogen en 2021
qui est une ancienne salariée de
Facebook et qui dit que facebook fait ça
de façon totalement consciente
totalement délibéré parce que le modèle
économique est une marchandisation de
notre attention plus nous restons sur
les réseaux plus nous voyons de
publicité plus l'entreprise fait de
profit avec des dégâts considérables oui
alors évidemment le débat judiciaire
sera délicat parce que le lien est
difficile à étbl mais malgré tout on le
sait il y a des troubles de la tension
il y a de l'anxiété il y a de la
dépression il y a du du suicide parfois
chez les plus jeunes il y a des troubles
du comportement alimentaire par l'image
du corps aussi qui qui est véhiculé par
tous ces réseaux par le voyurisme et
donc tout cela a sur nos enfants des
conséquences sanitaires et mentales
absolument dévastatrice d'un mot comment
a réagi Marc zukaberg ah bon alors là on
est dans le cynisme plus plus plus la
mauvaise foi absolument au carré au cube
puisqu'il explique que c'est quand même
dommage d'en arriver à cette
judiciarisation et qu'il aurait mieux
fallu dialoguer c'est quand même un
comble alors que de toute façon ça fait
15 ans qu'il fait des profits absolument
record en seoquant é perdument des
conséquences que son entreprise peut
avoir sur la santé des plus jeunes à ce
si près tout de même que là on est aux
États-Unis donc on cible deux
entreprises américaines Facebook et
Instagram mais d'autres pourraient
recevoir le même traitement et notamment
je pense au TikTok chinois qui a joue
exactement sur les mêmes mécanismes et
vous le savez peut-être aujourd'hui
c'est le No Twitter day c'est-à-dire un
jour où on est supposé se désintoxiquer
de Twitter et puisque Twitter est
désormais baptisé X et bien après la
plainte contre Facebook et Instagram on
aura peut-être la plainte contre X
quelle chute allez on enchaîne il nous
reste peu de temps vous allez être
attentif le philosophe que vous êtes
François Xavier bami parce qu'on a une
ologue qui chaque vendredi et bien nous
décortique remonte à la à la racine d'un
mot et ce mot ce soir c'est le mot
d'État un mot lourd un concept aussi
parce qu'on a beaucoup entendu à la fois
au proche- Orient mais aussi dans notre
pays oui quand on parle de la solution à
deux états aujourd'hui je crois que le
mot reprend une vigueur étymologique en
réentend le Staré latin qui veut bien
dire être debout être ferme et donc
donner de la stabilité on peut l'espérer
à une situation chaotique alors ça c'est
l'état repère nous en France on a plutôt
l'État providence voilà nous au lieu
d'avoir l'état repère on a plutôt disons
l'état Sainte Mère ou bonne mère he très
compassionnel le mot Providence est
religieux et donc on a cette cette idée
que bon benah dès qu'on parle à l'état
on peut faire appel à lui selon en plus
une relation très personnalisée hein
vous connaissez vous rappelez Louis XIV
l'État c'est moi mais on pourrait dire
qu'en France chaque citoyen a un peu
tendance à le dire avec l'amphibologie
enfin l'ambivalence du mot état c'est
aussi Myriam votre état physique notre
état d'esprit en c'est un mot qui va
bien aussi pour l'individu h et c'est
pour ça qu'on se tourne en France si
souvent vers l'état absolument et alors
là cette la situation internationale
nous oblige à rompre un petit peu avec
cette cet usage très compassionnel du
mot et à revenir à l'origine alors c'est
pas un mot très ancien état c'est un mot
moderne au sens historique du terme fin
du 15e début du 16e 17e donc de
Machiavel à HS par exemple on pourrait
dire c'est le socle et bien sûr là nous
avons l'état de droit contre l'état de
nature chez hops qui dans lequel selon
la formule qu'il a reprise au monde
latin bah l'homme peut-être un loup pour
l'homme donc vous voyez bien que ça
raisonne avec notre situation terrible
actuelle et je crois que c'est le moment
pour nous aussi en France de nous
interroger alors le mot droit il est
physique he Staré c'est être droit mais
je parle sous le contrôle de mon voisin
homme de loi et homme de droit
évidemment ce qui est intéressant c'est
quand ça se développe sur un plan
symbolique alors au Proche Orient il va
y avoir cette idée imaginons de deux
états de droit avec des systèmes
juridiques spécifiques qui pourront
converser mais qui seront aussi
certainement plus solides vis-àis de
d'intrusion idéologique qu'ils n'auront
pas demandé et chez nous c'est un peu la
même chose car nous sommes à un moment
terrible où l'État de droit ne
sanctuarise plus assez les choses hein
bien sûr l'école c'est tragique et on
l'a vu récemment donc mon point
là-dessus Miriam pour finir c'est que la
situation internationale nous fait
retrouver le sens de l'État comme
gardien des frontières qu'elle soit
réelle ou symbolique merci beaucoup
beaucoup merci Mariette on entend la
clochette je suis sûre que en dehors de
de ce studio vous pourrez commenter
espérer c'est-à-dire chez grass violence
histoire bonheure merci François x
béamine d'être passé sur notre plateau
et merci à vous les affranchi merci à
toutes les équipes de Ça vous regarde
derrière la caméra encore une belle
semaine c'est le weekend profitez bien à
la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
he